estamos ahora en el examen número 5 en
la sección número 7 página
669 así que empecemos como es una nueva
sección empezaré con el problema número
uno y el problema número uno dice lo
siguiente si k es un entero positivo
menor que 60 y divisible entre 3 cuál es
el valor máximo que puede tomar k
ok vamos a poner lo que es positivo
positivo
además es menor que 60 y eso lo voy a
poner así 0 es mayor que acá porque acá
es positivo pero que debe de ser menor
que 60 ok y además que es divisible
entre 3
divisible divisible entre 3 entre
ok lo que me preguntan es cuál es el
valor máximo que puede tomar cada bueno
pues vamos a explorar los números que
estén cercanos a camps qué te parece si
nosotros pensamos en 59
bueno pues recordamos de criterio de
visibilidad del 3 vamos a ver que el 59
no es múltiplo de 3 porque 59 vamos a
ponerlo aquí 5 más 9 esto es igual a 14
y 14 no es múltiplo de 3 por lo tanto 59
tampoco lo es que pasará con el 58 vamos
a pensar en el 58 vamos a sumar sus
dígitos 5 + 8 58 es lo mismo que 13 y 13
tampoco es múltiplo de 3 por lo tanto 58
tampoco es múltiplo de 3 y qué pasará
con 57 57 si sumamos los dígitos del 57
57 es igualdad 12 y 12 es múltiplo de 3
por lo tanto 57 va a ser múltiplo de 310
más hasta podemos hacer la división
57 entre 3
1 1 por 3 3 para 5 esto si llevamos nada
después bajamos el 7 y 99 por 327 menos
27 me da 0 el residuo cero por lo tanto
57 es un múltiplo de 3 además tiene toda
la lógica del mundo porque 60 era el
múltiplo de 3 y si le quitamos 3 a 60 me
va a dar 57 por lo tanto el valor máximo
que puede tomar camps es 57 que es el
inciso sé muy bien vamos al problema
número 2 el problema número 2 me dice lo
siguiente la letra h es simétrica con
respecto a dos rectas las cuales se
muestran a continuación igual de las
silletas letras es simétrica al menos
dos rectas ok vamos a hablar de la letra
h así que déjame dibujar primero aquí
una letra h de este color la letra h ok
date cuenta que en primer lugar está la
letra h que por cierto esto no sabes
simétrico esta letra h tiene un eje de
simetría justo aquí existe una recta que
la puede cruzar por aquí de tal manera
que me den dos figuras iguales si yo
volteo esta parte de la letra es decir
que esta figura está de aquí
y estar acá son exactamente iguales yo
puedo doblar esta letra y me quedaría
exactamente lo mismo esta sería la forma
de ver a la letra h bajo un eje de
simetría bajo una recta pero también
podemos tener aquí en mi letra h mi
letra h original y después ver que aquí
tenemos otra recta que cuando nosotros
nos tomamos a esa recta como el eje de
simetría nos quedan dos cosas iguales
nos quedarían esta parte de arriba esta
de aquí y por otra parte nos quedaría
esta parte de abajo esta de aquí y los
dos son iguales es decir que si nosotros
doblamos a esta letra vamos a obtener
exactamente lo mismo y bueno si tú te
fijas en todas tus opciones te vas a dar
cuenta que la letra que le pasa justo lo
mismo es la equis la equis fíjate bien
la equis tiene dos ejes de simetría el
primero sería este de por aquí estoy por
aquí porque si te das cuenta esta parte
déjame cambiar de color
esta parte es exactamente igual a la
otra parte de azul estas dos partes son
iguales y además tengo otro eje de
simetría si yo pongo la letra x
y tomo ahora esta recta como eje de
simetría lo que me queda arriba de la
recta es exactamente igual a lo que me
queda abajo de la recta lo que me queda
arriba es exactamente igual que lo que
me queda abajo perfecto por lo tanto es
la letra x y vamos al siguiente problema
problema número uno número dos de génova
de la pantalla y vamos a poner el
problema número tres el problema número
tres dice o es un problema si bernardo
recibe dos pesos por cada trabajo que él
realice en la semana más un sueldo fijo
de diez pesos y además sabemos que
bernardo sólo recibe ese dinero
mencionado cuál de las siguientes
expresiones representa el dinero que
obtiene bernardo a la semana por
realizar n trabajos ok veamos qué es lo
que pasa si bernardo acm trabajos si
bernardo base de trabajos m trabajos
entonces por cada uno de estos trabajos
que hagan le van a pagar dos pesos
entonces le van a pagar dos pesos por
cada uno de estos trabajos que hagan si
él hace cinco trabajos entonces va a
recibir por 510 pesos si la hace tres
trabajos va a recibir dos por 33 pesos
pero qué pasa si enlaces 0 trabajos qué
tal si esta semana no realice ningún
trabajo bueno pese a ello nos dice el
problema que bernardo recibe un sueldo
fijo de 10 pesos es decir que si
bernardo no hace ningún trabajo aún así
le van a dar 10 pesos como sueldo fijo
le van a dar 10 pesos ok por lo tanto la
expresión que representa el dinero que
obtiene bernardo va a ser justo esta
verdad no va a recibir 10 pesos de
sueldo fijo más 2 pesos por cada trabajo
que haga este sería el dinero que recibe
bernardo y que depende de m ok aquí está
mi expresión y vamos a pensar en el
problema número 4 el problema número 4
que tiene una figura la figura siguiente
dice los cuadrados de menor tamaño en la
figura y en la figura b tienen la misma
medida para que te des cuenta de aquel
cuadrados me refiero me gusta este
ecuador
tomemos primero un rectángulo más o
menos así tengo un rectángulo más o
menos así y después tengo otro porque
pasa por la mitad tengo otro rectángulo
más o menos así ok y es algo muy
parecido a esto aquí tengo otro pequeño
cuadrado algo así ok y después aquí
tengo una recta y déjame tomar esta
línea tengo una recta que cruza por acá
ok
otra recta que cruza por acá hasta
llegar a este ok después tengo otra
recta que cruza por acá no no no espera
otra recta que cruzar por acá ok esta es
la figura y entonces deja de poner que
esta es la figura bueno por otra parte
tengo a la figura y la figura ve es muy
parecida a estrategia me cambiado de
color
tengo algo así ok
y después tengo aquí un cuadrado que
salen ok o no no no no me gusta un
cuadrado que sale por aquí
porque este se divide la mitad esto es
algo así
ok después es algo así
entonces tengo un cuadrado que sale por
aquí ok algo más o menos así tengo otro
cuadrado que sale por acá ok perfecto
entonces tengo todos estos a uno no y
además tengo otros dos por acá tengo
otros dos por acá algo así y algo así
ok esta es mi figura letra be ok
entonces vamos a pensar qué es lo que me
dice el problema si el área de a el área
de todo a es igual a 26 centímetros
cuadrados a tiene como área 26
centímetros cuadrados
26 centímetros cuadrados y cada uno de
estos es un cuadrado igual a todos los
demás y también es igual a los cuadrados
de ver cuál es el área de bem ok pues
qué te parece si nosotros pensamos
cuántos cuadrados hay en a para ver cuál
es el área de cada uno de estos
cuadrados pequeños vamos a contarlos
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 y este es el
13 es decir que tengo 13 cuadrados de la
misma área por lo tanto yo puedo decir
que 13 cuadrados de la misma variable
web ponerse de cuadrados es igual a 26
centímetros cuadrados con dicho otra
manera cada uno de estos cuadraditos
vale 2 centímetros cuadrados que por
cierto es lo mismo que vale este
cuadrado de aquí que es lo mismo que
vale este cuadrado de acá por lo tanto
vamos a contar cuántos cuadrados tiene b
b tiene 1 2 3 4 3 4 5 6 7 y 8 por lo
tanto el área debe podemos decir que es
ocho veces lo que vale el área de cada
uno de los cuadrados pero cada uno de
los cuadrados vale dos centímetros
entonces sustituyendo me va a quedar que
el área debe es 8 por 2 lo cual es 16
centímetros cuadrados perfecto entonces
la respuesta es el inciso c en el inciso
sem que son 16 centímetros cuadrados y
por cierto el problema número 3 tiene
como respuesta el inciso de ok vamos al
siguiente problema el problema número 5
y para esto déjame borrar la pantalla ok
y el problema número 5 también tiene una
gráfica o no es muy cansado dibujar
gráficas y aunque sal se cansa un poco
de hacer todas estas gráficas intento
hacer mi mejor esfuerzo y por eso lo
hago con mucho gusto así que venga pues
tengo esta gráfica amd y tengo por aquí
las escalas esta les voy a poner porque
creo que me sirven tengo aquí 150 o
dejemos que la herramienta aquí es 150
ok por acá tengo 300
300 y entonces por acá está 200 y por
acá está
250 ok más o menos se ve algo así y
tengo los siguientes ángulos tengo un
rectángulo por acá que empieza en 300 y
baja como por acá esto es la cantidad de
producto que va a vender antonio después
tengo un rectángulo que está como el 150
algo parecido a esto
ok tengo un rectángulo más o menos como
éste tengo otro que está como en 220 200
a lobo ya dibujar más o menos como por
acá
ok tengo este de acá
después tengo otro que está como en 250
algo más o menos como por acá ok
perfecto y por último tengo otro más o
menos de la misma altura tengo otro más
o menos de la misma altura ok y por otra
parte tengo rectángulos de otro color de
este color y tengo un rectángulo más o
menos parecido a este ok después tengo
otro que es más o menos parecido a este
es algo o no es pérez pero es algo más o
menos así no espera un poco más para acá
es algo más o menos así
perfecto después tengo otro muy parecido
a este ok es algo más o menos así
después tengo otro que bajan es algo
como parecido a éste okay baja como por
aquí y por último tengo uno que es un
poco más grande que éste es como 300
315 algo así ok ya tengo aquí mis
rectángulos y por cierto cada uno de
estos son vendedores aquí tengo el
vendedor que se llama antonio o no deja
de cambiar de herramienta
este es el vendedor que se llama antonio
este es el vendedor que se llama
bernardo este es carlos aquí está daniel
y por último está ernesto
ernesto perfecto este es mi eje x este
es mi eje game y lo que me pregunta el
problema es lo siguiente de acuerdo a la
gráfica siguiente a esta de aquí que ha
vendedor tiene el mayor incremento en la
venta por unidad de sus productos del
año 1998 al año 1999 así que es muy
importante que te diga que por cierto
este siempre va a ser el rectángulo de
color azul del año
1998 y los rectángulos de color morado
este de aquí son en el año 1999
1999 ok ahora cuál de estos vendedores
tiene un incremento mayor en la venta de
unidades por año y bueno en una primera
instancia podemos decir que antonio no
es porque antonio no incrementa su venta
antonio disminuye su venta decrece su
venta por lo tanto se puede decir
rapidísimo que antonio no es y también
de una misma manera daniel decrece su
venta baja su venta y por lo tanto dan
día no incrementa su venta así que
también tampoco es y vamos a ver con los
demás vendedores bernardo aumenta de
aquí hasta acá de aquí hasta acá del año
1998 al año 1999
ok carlos carlos aumenta solamente esto
de aquí mientras que por otra parte
ernesto aumenta solamente esto de aquí
por lo tanto de una manera muy visible
muy intuitiva nos podemos dar cuenta que
la respuesta correcta es ve el inciso b
que es bernardo bernardo es el que más
le echó ganas a estas ventas del año
1988 al año 1999 pues tuvo el mayor
incremento en la venta por unidad de
estos productos así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo